Wonder Woman dominated at the box office
this weekend with some of the best
reviews ever for a superhero movie and a
record opening for a female director it
was also the rare DC Comics movie that
wasn't so dark and brooding you think it
was written through a cloud of babe
smoke and a hot topic breakroom but but
of course not everyone was thrilled
about it they always in touch and never
insane pundits at Fox News complained
that Wonder Woman wasn't patriotic
enough they were upset that her outfit
wasn't red white and blue and that the
movie didn't mention America enough well
I guess that would make sense except
that one woman is in American there's a
thing about that this is not it's not
American she's not American anyone who's
even passingly familiar with the
character knows that she's from the
island of the miss Cora or famous Kira
as she says it in the movie originally
known as paradise island before the
crisis on Infinite Earths storyline in
1985 well maybe they're more familiar
with Justice League stories or Wonder
Woman's often seen the league's
watchtower except oh wait that's on the
moon quad and the last time I checked
the moon was not in America even though
they're apparently there is a flag on
there somewhere so who knows who knows
maybe you guys are right maybe I'm right
but I feel like maybe I know a little
more about continuity the Fox News bitch
that's why it's a song and also really
great job jerking yourselves off about
Wonder Woman outfit colors on a news
channel because there's nothing else
going on in the world at the moment you
guys so comedians what's another
complaint foxnews has about a big summer
movie dawn daily well Sean Hannity was
saying that Captain Underpants wasn't
sexy enough all right I like lose the
underpants dude what's Underpants
yes underpants yes Alan all the
characters and cars through your goddamn
hippie hybrids
all right Boyd bud yes now I'm not a
mathematician but um I think the
Caribbean is somewhere close to America
sessions there being American pirate of
the Caribbean yeah
yeah
[Applause]